Writing is a way of contributing
to the political climate
and saying something meaningful,
because not all of us
are going to run for office.
I'm never going
to run for office.
My past is filthy.
Writing is such a great
career, but you definitely
don't need to be a writer
to enjoy this class.
For one, I'm
incredibly charming.
Writing has always
influenced public opinion.
It's one of the
most effective means
of reaching a great
number of people
and to get other people on
board with progressive ideas
like women are people
and Black Lives Matter,
and everyone should
have health care.
I know that these are
very radical ideas,
but writing for social
change is really
just writing to make a
difference in this world.
In this MasterClass,
you're going
to learn how to write better,
think deeper, and contribute
your voice to the
world in valuable ways;
and we're going to talk about
the business of publishing
and how to really get a start.
One of the things
that we should always
try to do as writers
is to figure out
what can you bring to this
discussion that no one else
can.
I mean, that feels
more fun to me.
Isn't it more fun?
Yeah.
Perfection is not the
goal when you're writing,
excellence is.
"Hunger" is a memoir that
I wrote about my body,
and it starts with a sexual
assault I experienced when
I was 12, and I turned to
food as a source of comfort
and as a source of
protection, thinking
that if I made myself
bigger, I would become safer.
"My body is a cage.
My body is a cage
of my own making.
I'm still trying to
figure my way out of it.
I have been trying
to figure my way out
of it for more than 20 years."
It was a very difficult book
to write because I was afraid.
You don't need to be
brave when you're writing.
You need to acknowledge
that you're terrified,
and do it anyway.
But don't think that
trauma is the only thing
you have to offer.
You can write about anything.
Writing, for a lot of people,
ends up being salvation,
and when writing finds you,
when writing saves you,
it opens up a whole new
world of possibility,
and I hope that certainly
is the case for you.
I'm Roxane Gay, and
this is my MasterClass.